مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه واخر الانباء المتعلقه بها
نستضيف كالعاده المحلل العسكري اللواء
فايز الدويري مرحبا بك سيد
فايز مشاهدينا بدايه اخر تطورات المشهد
ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه مع اخر
التحديثات والمعلومات وعبد القادر عرض عبد
القادر نعم حسن ولعلني ساختصر المش في اخر
التطورات والعواجل التي نقلناها على
شاشتنا حيث تشير هذه العواجل نقلا عن
مصادر اسرائيليه الى تطورات لافته واعلان
يقول هذا الاعلان وفق هذه المصادر
الاسرائيليه على ان هذا اليوم كان ربما
اليوم الاقصى في تاريخ حرب اسرائيل
المعلنه منذ السابعه من اكتوبر حربها على
غزه وذلك بمقتل تسعه ضباط وجنود
اسرائيليين اسرائيليين وذلك في هجومين
لعلنا هنا حينما نتحدث عن المنطقه
الشماليه نحن نشير الى مواقع اشتباك واسعه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه كانت هنا في مخيم
جباليا في جباليه في التفاح في الدرج ايضا
في جبل الريس كانت هناك ايضا اشتباكات في
منطقه الشيخ رضوان المنطقه الشماليه اذا
كانت ساحه لاشتباكات ظلت المقاومه تقول
فيها كلمتها هذا الاعلان من المصادر
الاسرائيليه عن مقتل جنود اسرائيليين ت
ضباط بين ضباط وجنود في هجومين الهجوم
الاول تمثل في في في انفجار شاحنه شاحنه
معباه بالذخائر في جنود اسرائيليين اما
الثاني فكان من خلال عمليات استهداف وقصف
لمبنى كان فيه جنود اسرائيليون اذا هذه
التطورات المتلاحقه وهذا الاعلان عن هذا
اليوم الاقصى كما تقول المصادر
الاسرائيليه ياتي ايضا بينما كانت ايضا
الجبهات الاخرى مثل جبهه الوسط مسرحا يضا
اداء للمقاومه خصوصا في منطقه البريج
تابعنا مؤتمرا صحفيا للمتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي والذي قال بان منطقه الوسطى
ايضا من المناطق التي شهدت
اشتباكات قويه مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ربما المنطقه ايضا الاخرى وهي المنطقه
الجنوبيه منطقه خانيونس التي تابعنا
تطوراتها اليوم خصوصا
المناطق الشرقيه
والمناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه هي ايضا مواقع
للاشتباك فبالتالي لم يعلن اين سقط هؤلاء
الجنود التسعه ولكن المناطق الثلاث
الشماليه وايضا الوسطى والجنوبيه ظلت
مسرحا لاعلانات للمقاومه تابعنا فيديوهات
تعلن المقاومه عن عمليات استهداف لهؤلاء
الجنود ربما اللافت ايضا والحاله النفسيه
من خلال الاعلان على ان ربع تقريبا 9000
جندي اسرائيلي اصيبوا باضطرابات نفسيه لم
يعودوا الى الخدمه اذا هي معطيات مرتبطه
بتطورات الحرب على مستوى كل هذه الجبهات
ولكن تاتي ايضا بينما ظلت صواريخ المقاومه
تصل الى مديات بعيده ولعل ننا تابعنا ما
اعلنته القسام عن استهداف تل ابيب وايضا
ما اعلنته المقاومه عن استهداف مواقع في
غلاف غزه اذا هي تطورات لافته تحتاج الى
قراءه عوده اليك حسن فعلا عبد القادر
وايضا في اطار هذه الرشقات الصاروخيه
مراسل الجزيره تحدث قبل قليل ايضا عن
اطلاق رشقه صاروخيه من شمال قطاع غزه
باتجاه اي مستوطنات غلاف غزه ومدن في
اسرائيل اللواء فياز الدويري سابدا معك
اولا بهذا الخبر المتعلق بمقتل تسعه ضباط
وجنود اسرائيليين في معارك قطاع غزه خلال
الارب 24 ساعه والوصف الذي اعطته مصادر
اسرائيليه لليوم بانه الاقصى على جيش
الاحتلال في في هذه الحرب اولا كيف قرات
ذلك يعني اولا هو
اعتراف يختلف عن الاعترافات السابقه مر
ثلاث ايام كانت يتحدث عن اصابات لما يتحدث
عن قتله لما لم اذكر انني سمعت في اي خبر
او من اي متحدث كان هناك اصابات اصابات لا
يوجد قتله في هذا اليوم ظهر هذا
الرقم هو الاقسى قياسا مع الايام الماضيه
حسب اعلانات الجيش الاحتلال نعم هل الرقم
دقيق ام غير دقيق قد يكون غير دقيق لانه
اذا اعدنا وعرضنا اشرطه
الفيديو ق قد يقول قائلا ان هذه الاشرطه
لا تحمل تاريخ نفس اليوم نقول له يمكن ذلك
ولكنها تحمل تاريخ مؤطر ما بين في حدها
الاقصى 72 ساعه بناع تصريحات ابو عبيده
وما دون ذلك اذا اخذنا اي فيديوهات عرضت
نجد ان رقم القتلى من خلال نوع الاصابه
التي شاهدناها نعم يعطي رقم اكبر مما تم
الاعتراف به لكنه جاء اعترافا واضحا لانه
يبدو يحمل مضامين معينه ان هناك حرب قاسيه
هناك ثمن باهظ ندفعه وهذه الجمله ثمن باهظ
هو حديث احد المسؤولين الاسرائيليين فكانه
بدا الافصاح الجزئي والارتقاء ب بتقديم
اعداد اكبر مما تم الاعتياد عليه تمهيدا
لخطوات اللاحقه طيب
بال نود نود الان ان
اي نشير الان الى صور الان يخبرون الزملاء
عن صور جديده ل رشقات صاروخيه
هي التي تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل وظهرت في
الخبر العاجل من شمال قطاع غزه على ما
اعتقد كان الخبر العاجل يشير الى ان هذه
الصواريخ من شمال قطاع غزه لما لها من
دلاله ان تنطلق الصواريخ من الشمال اعتقد
هي رساله واضحه واجابه قاطعه على تصريح
وزير الدفاع عندما قال يعني تم السيطره
بصوره كبيره جدا
على القطاع
الشمالي بقي بعض القدرات يعني لا يستبعد
بقاء بعض المقاتلين في المنطقه وبعض
الرهائن اذا هو كانه استثنى القدرات بقي
بعض المقاتلين وبعض الرهائن وبالتالي هذا
الامر يحتاج الى اليه اخرى للبحث فجاء
الرد بان اطلاق الصواريخ سواء كانت على
الغلاف او انا لا اعلم هل هي التي ذهبت
الى تلبيب ام ذهبت الى الغلاف ايا كان هي
نفس الرساله هذه هذه صور مختلفه عن الصور
لكتائب القسام التي اعلنت فيها التي اعلنت
فيها عن قصف تل ابيب هذه الصور خاصه
بالجزيره لدفعه هذا المساء يا سيدي في
العاده لا يتم الاعلان عن مكان الاطلاق
وبالتالي نفترض انه من نقطه ماء داخل
جغرافيا غزه لكن الان انا قلت
في لسبب في نفسي لم يتم الاعلان من اين
اطلقت وهل وهل هذه هذا الاعلان هو عن التي
ذهبت الى تلي ابيب الان انا اشرت الى
خلفيه معينه في الحديث الاطلاق واجابه على
تساؤلك من شمال قطاع غزه الارجح ان
الصواريخ التي ذهبت الى الغراف هي التي
اطلقت من شمال غزه ولكن انا اضع افتراض
اخر هل يعقل هل هل ممكن ان كذلك التي ذهبت
الى لا تلي ابيه من شمال غزه لماذا هذا
يقودني الى معطى معين ان كتائب المقاومه
القسام والجهاد لا يزال لديهم القدره في
المنطقه الشماليه التي افترض انه تم
السيطره عليها وانه بدا
بالتهيئه للمرحله الثالثه وبدا بسحب
القوات ولم يتبقى الا اجزاء بسيطه في نقاط
محدده فجاء الخبر لين في صحه المزاعم هذه
صورور من سديروت في غلاف غزه شاهدنا
الاطلاق وهنا شاهدنا اعتراض هذه الصواريخ
في سماء ديرو سرو نعم يا سيدي انا هذا
الامر عادي والاعتراض القبه الحديديه تعمل
كفائتها 65 ل 70% ولكن هي كفائتها 65 حتى
نكون دقيقين ام كفاءه الاداء للقبه
الحديديه تقديري الشخصي من متابعاتي لاكثر
من حرب يقع بين 65 الى 70% من الصواريخ
التي يتم اعتراضها وليس من مجمل الصواريخ
التي تطلق نعم و يعني نعود لنشير الى ان
هذه الدفعه مختلفه عن الدفعه الاولى التي
اشرنا اليها والتي ذهبت الى تل ابيب وهذه
من شمال قطاع غزه استهدفت رود بالدرجه
الاولى ونشاهد هنا بال الصور محاولات
اعتراض القبه الحديديه لبعض هذه
الصواريخ
ام اود اود ايضا في في مساله اطلاق
اي لا ادري ان كنا
سنستمر مع مع هذه المشاهد لانها هي
المشاهد الجديده قبل قليل كنا قد اشرنا
وا بثي مشاهد حصلت عليها الجزيره من كتائب
القسام
ل
استهداف تلبيب برشقات صاروخيه وتحدثنا
عنها كثيرا لكن ايضا ما هي الدلاله ل
لاستهداف تل ابيب برشقه صاروخيه يا سيدي
يعني الدلاله كما قلنا هي رسائل تح يعني
هذا هذه الصواريخ تحمل متفجرات نعم ولكنها
تحمل مضامين اهم المضامين المضامين
السياسيه ومن ثم المضامين العسكريه وما
حتى بضيف لها مضامين مجتمعيه كيف المضامين
السياسيه هي عباره عن تكذيب واضح لما
يتحدث به المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين مضامين سياسيه هي رساله الى
البيت الابيض والى وزير الخارجيه بلينكن
رغم كل دعمك لا
تزال لا يزال الكيان عاجز عن تقديم شيء
امامك نعم المضامين الاجتماعيه لا يتزال
رساله الى المجتمع ان مسؤولي غير صادقين
طيب اود ان اشير الى هذه الصور هذه صور
لجنود اسرائيليين سقطوا في المعارك وهذه
استهدافات لطالما شاهدناها وعلقنا عنها
علقنا عليها واشرنا اليها لكن الان
بمناسبه الحديث عن القتلى التسعه من
الضباط والجنود وفق
مصادر اسرائيل
اللافت ان هذا العدد ياتي بعد اعلان
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي عن تكتيكات
جديده في الحرب واليات جديده في القتال
لتقليل عدد القتلى والمصابين في جيش
الاحتلال فاذا بهذه
الحصيله الكبيره يعني الان نتحدث عن تسعه
يعني ه التسعه قد يتم حصدهم بعربه النمر
اذا كانت الاصابه قاتله عربه عربه النمر
تحمل 11 فردا ام قد يكون فيها ضابط واحد
لكن بم انه الحديث عن ضباط اذا تم استهداف
اكثر من اليه سواء الان التدمير القتل حدث
داخل اليات او حدث بالقنص او حدث بالشوا
الخبر يقول انه باحد الهجومين استهدف على
ما يبدو اليه انفجرت نتيجه الهجوم انفجرت
الذخيره بدا
والهج الاخر كان استهداف لجنود اسرائيليين
في مبنى يا سيدي الان نتحدث عن تي بي جي
ونتحدث عن تاندم
وبالتالي ما هو عدد الجنود داخل المبنى هل
هناك فرضا سبعه منهم ثلاثه ضباط بغض النظر
اذا لكن الشاحنه التي تحمل
ذخيره لا عاده لا يحمل فيها
افراد كل جيوش العالم فقط السائق والدليل
يعني اذا اردت نقل ذخيره من مكان الى اخر
في حساباتي لا يمكن ان احمل بها الجنود
انما يكون في السياره الحد الادنى المفروض
توفره واذا كنت بحاجه لتامين حمايه
الذخيره من اي حدث طارئ تكون مجموعه
الحمايه في سياره خلف السياره التي تحمل
الذخيره هكذا هي اسس نقل الذخيره اسس نقل
واذا كانت قافله من السيارات تكون معها
حمايه تسير في الامام والخلف هنا اذا كانت
سياره تحمل ذخيره وتحمل فوقها الجنود فهذا
يعني فوق الجبن غباء يعني عذرا وبالتالي
يعني التفاصيل الدقيقه كيفيه توزيع عدد
القتلى لا نستطيع ان نحدد لكن بما انه في
داخل مبنى اي تاندم يستطيع ان يقتل العد
تي بي جي يستطيع ان يقتل العدد اذا كانوا
في عربه نمر اي تان يستطيع ان يقتل هذا
العدد انا شخصيا لا اقتنع بان هذا العدد
هو الحد الاقصى في الخساره اليوميه هذا
الحد الاقصى فيما قدم من بيانات الحد الحد
الاقصى قد يكون اكثر بكثير في معظم الايام
طبعا هذا بالنظر الى ما كنا نتابعه من
مشاهد
للمعارك وللاستخدام
في غزه في
مختلف المناطق ا كان شالا او جنوبا او حتى
في الوسط يا سيدي
الان عند عند التوقف امام الفيديوهات التي
عرضت من اول فيديو حتى اخر
فيديو يستطيع اي محلل لديه معلومات جيده
عن اليه او كيف تدار المعركه يستطيع ان
يخرج بخلاصات نعم وبالتالي هذه الفيديوهات
في احد الايام انا شاهدت تدمير خمس دبابات
ب
خمسه قواذف طيب ب فيديو واحد هذه الدبابات
ميركافا اربعه الحد الادنى للطاقم الموجود
بداخلها اربع
اشخاص الامر
السائق المعبئ
و المسؤول عن الاتصالات لكن في تصميم
الاله من الخلف فيها حجره ت تتسع سته
اشخاص اذا هذه الدبابه في الحد الاقصى
يوجد بها عره انا كمحلل عندما اشاهد تدمير
الاله اقول 4 + 10 14 ت 2 7 طيب على على
على الوسط الحسابي طيب الان
يعني هذا ما كنت تكرره وتقوله
دائما اليوم المصادر الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن
الجنود والضباط التسعه في معارك غزه وتصفه
بانه اليوم
الاقصى
للمفارق القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه
تحدثت عن رقيب في الجيش الاسرائيلي
اي مات لانه لم
يتحمل ما حصل لجنود جيش الاحتلال يعني هو
كان يشاهد كيف كانوا يقتلون وهذا ما لم
يكن يتحدث عنه المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان دائما يتحدث عن جرحى وب
باعداد قليله هذا رقيب مات بسكته قلبيه
لانه لم يتحمل المنظر المنظر مكان يحل
بجنود الاحتلال اثناء معاركهم في غزه يا
سيدي يعني شاهدنا كثير من الفيديوهات
استمعنا لكثير من التعليقات لكن في كثير
من الحالات ف تعرف عالم السوشيال ميديا لا
يمكن ان تاخذ كل معلومه في السوشيال ميديا
كانها مسلمه مسلم بها اذا اخذنا بتلك
الاراء حديثه يعني وفاه هذا الشخ شخص اي
متوقعه جدا ام لانه كان التسجيلات يصرخ
اين قدمي اين يدي اين كذا الم يقم احد
الجنود في الليل ويطلق النار على الجدار
في الغرفه ويصيب بعض زملائه ولم يحاكم في
تلك الفتره مراعاه اذا كانوا مصابين بهوس
اسمه القسام نعم وهذا السبب ربما
الذي جعل الالاف من جنود الاحتلال يحتاجون
الى مع معالجات نفسيه شكرا جزيلا لك
اللواء فيز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي